when did this idea first come to you how
long's this one been in you know
gestation is over a long time this one
probably longer than any thing I've ever
worked on since the beach I guess the
beach came out of years and years of
backpacking and this came out of years
and years of being interested in
computers and interested in AI is in
particular and also interested in
consciousness in human consciousness and
because a lot of the problems of AIS are
also the same as the problems of
consciousness trying to define what our
brains are and what our minds are I've
been reading about that for a long time
and I'm lucky enough to have a couple of
friends were very interested in the same
subject and knowledgeable about it so I
was able to talk to them about it and
then I started reading a lot and it
emerged as a story I was working on this
film dred a few years ago and in prep on
Dredd they suddenly arrived as a as a
narrative in my head it just popped out
it's changed a bit since then but the
core idea remained the same so 10 years
10 years and when when that narrative
came to you to you did you then sort of
switch away from dread and go and sit in
a room and get it down really quickly
yes yes Ali what I did I wrote it down
on my methodology with scripts or
anything really is to write one or two
pages a4 scribble it down the key beats
and and then to put that at the bottom
of the document and gradually start
writing it later deleting the lines as
you get to them and get to the last line
then you finish the script that's kind
of the the process and them so I did I
got this down really quick because
basically as a writer currency for me as
stories that's and and if I come across
a story that is meaningful to me as
that's actually very valuable
I need those things so yeah I'd I'd
write [ __ ] great concentration I'm in
messing this down and then when and did
you know at that point that this was the
one that you
wanted to direct because I I kind of
assumed you would direct I it seemed to
me logical that you would um I I don't
want this to sound disingenuous it's not
it it's just true I've been working
films for years I just see it as
filmmaking I've never I don't attach
huge importance to directing I don't
in a way attach huge importance to any
of the roles except that they have their
own implicit importance I just don't
really go with the pyramid structure
it's never I've worked on too many films
where it's clearly not the case so it I
just don't buy into it and it's
filmmaking and there's a group of
filmmakers
and they include production designers
and do B's and producers and writers and
directors and actors and often at
different points in a filmmaking process
different people have primacy you know
it changes where we from the outside its
presented as if it's always this thing
it's not been released in my experience
it isn't and so I didn't see it I know
it seems like a big step but for me it
wasn't a big step I feel like I've been
making film for fifteen years here's
another one I could work on another one
where someone else is directing it I
wouldn't then think I've now given up of
myself to this other person I'd I just I
don't go along with it and so yeah
Eliseo was saying you were very calm
answer it did you feel calm and ya
thought totally calm
yeah it was a lot of that crew I've
worked with many times like really many
many times and in fact domhnall gleeson
of work with many times these are
friendly faces yet and we've with some
of the films we've worked on in the past
have been really extremely difficult and
one of the intentions on this film is a
very bluntly expressed intention is this
film is not going to be like this this
is going to be a friendly collegiate
experience and the only bit of fascism
in the film was that you know and and so
yeah I felt calm because I was
surrounded by people who are
terrifically good at their jobs I mean
not just
good really really good and over the
years of you know I've got very
dependent and close on some of these
it's close to and dependent on these
people some of them I haven't worked
with before the DOP Rob never worked
with him before hugely important in this
film hugely part of the team one of the
reasons I don't like that directing
stuff is I feel like I'm taking away
from someone like the DOP yeah
implicitly
I saw a trailer for film the other day I
knew immediately who shot it
absolutely immediately everyone who is
responding to that trailer then talks
about this guy's new film coming out
everything they're responding to really
in that trailer is is the DOP really so
I come at this from a different angle
yeah let's talk about the car show you
three main characters two other
characters but three main characters
really I guess maybe four so a lot on
their shoulders are casting always
important but vital in this one there
that's always using it must be a did you
did you have Alicia in mind was she
somebody on your radar had because Ava
is she was on the radar definitely right
but because of the dis Danish movie she
did rural affair Brooke which she very
young actress and she OH
acting opposite I think Mads Mikkelsen
very power fighter and she just
dominates the film and you spot that
immediately yeah I don't mean dominates
in a bad way I just mean you can take
her eyes your eyes or phone just the
thing about this film was I had the
there were moments of anxiety right and
there always are what my my most acute
moment of anxiety was when it came to
Casting because casting at this budget
which was 15 million dollars is
completely bound up in whether you'll
get financed and what I didn't want was
to cast stars not because stars are not
good or helpful they can be terrific a
useful in a film but because because of
the way this film is constructed because
of the kind of script as because of the
length of the scenes and the complex
the acting job it had to go to people
who are primarily actors they may or may
not turn into stars or be stars but more
than anything they have to be real
actors the film would collapse instantly
under the weight of of one of those
people who has terrific charisma but but
not much else in terms of chops you know
so yeah it was cast for actors and and
and I'm very I'm genuinely grateful to
the producers and also the finances that
they got that and they did not say if
it's not one of the names on this very
short list we're not giving you the
money they said no we get it we can see
the kind of thing it is and so so what
we got was three people who it's not
like they're unknowns right everybody in
the industry knew these guys are good
lots of other people trying to get them
for other things it's not a secret Oscar
Isaacs a sensation right everybody knew
that but he's also not something at that
point you could finance a movie on the
background how did you approach either
in particular Ava but because it's a
tough one for this year's me it's yes
actuality the humanity with the machine
that you did you talk that through with
her a lot and did you did you sort of
find that together no no not really I I
wrote the script she read it we had a
conversation and she was just right on
the money
everything she said was right on the
money and she had some particular
thoughts about particular moments that
made me think you really understand this
you really thought about this or
intuitively you get it whatever it is
you get it so that's great she also had
some points about movement about
physicality which she was able to
control in a particular kind of way good
actors are always very good at
controlling their Oddie her ballerina
training I think gives her another edge
she was a trick she was a work for years
a very high level as a ballerina
and it gave her it gave her the little
sort of x-factor ish thing to chuck in
there as well and it's about a nuanced
presentation of a machine not big clunky
movements which is what I do the cameras
on me but something much so something
other she could make she could make over
something other doesn't push you away
brings you in but also keeps you
hovering just offer it's kind of
brilliant question - absolutely
to state the obvious is a very
thought-provoking film and it made me
think about a lot of things - cool good
what thank you how close do you think we
are to ai ai exists in many forms at the
moment all but what you're talking about
is the interesting thing is all very
sentient yes yeah self-aware yeah um
it's unknowable I I know some people now
in the process of working on this film
who are right at the cutting edge I mean
the cutting edge of this stuff and what
I would say is in my opinion for what
it's worth I think it's going to happen
I really do think it's going to happen
there's a there's a serious school of
thought that says it's not going to
happen and I think they're wrong I think
it is going to happen when it happens is
another matter it's got a cure for
cancer aspect about that you know as you
turn one corner you see another obstacle
but that doesn't mean a progression
isn't happening in my lifetime probably
just my kids lifetime yeah that that's
where I put it
yeah and and it's going to change
everything it is everything everything
everything all all the paradigms of our
existence that we basically existed with
for since homo sapiens arrived 200
thousand years all that's going to
change mortality we're bound to it
we both aged since we last saw each
other
that'll stop yeah
not for us but for something else
sentient
you